- [Voiceover] On the number line above,
the tick marks are equally spaced
and their coordinates are shown.
Of these coordinates,
which has the smallest
positive value?
So this is interesting.
These are equally spaced.
We start at negative eight and we have
one, two, three, four,
five, six equal spaces
to get all the way to 10.
So what must be the space
between these tick marks here?
Well, to go from negative eight to 10,
to go all the way from
negative eight to 10,
you have increased by 18
or the difference between
negative eight and 10 is 18.
You have to go eight to get to zero
and then 10 more to get to 10.
So this distance is 18.
We've split it into six sections,
six equal sections.
So 18 divided by six,
each of these sections must
have a length of three.
So they each have a length of three.
So now we can figure out the values
of A, B, C, D and E.
A gets us to negative five.
I'm just adding three each time.
B is at negative two
and then you add three,
you get to C, which is at one
and we've already answered our question.
This is the smallest positive value.
We went from the most
negative, we keep increasing
and this is the first of the choices.
This is the first positive value we hit.
So C has the smallest
positive, positive value.
Then we could keep
going if you're curious.
D, you're going to add another three.
D is four.
E is seven and then you add three more
and we get to 10.
We wanted the smallest positive value
out of the choices,
and that's going to be C.